a few weeks ago to back it up we ran a
fake commercial with our good friend
Nick Offerman in which Nick is making
handcrafted wooden emojis here is a
cliff in that bit and that's why I'm
proud to introduce my new line of
handcrafted solid wood emojis messages
you can build with my hand-carved wood
emojis include I love you and I love
cats and I love you but I'm sad that the
cat was not for a real product but then
a strange thing happened we heard from a
bunch of people who said they'd love to
have a wooden emoji for real for real
they want a real wooden emoji so last
night we announced that we were selling
100 of the solid wood emojis with all
all the proceeds going to a great
charity The Children's Defense Fund okay
well guess what we aired this last night
the response was overwhelming all 100 of
the emojis sold in less than 19 minutes
immediately
that means there are a ton of people who
didn't have a chance to get their hands
on one of these impractical completely
useless hunks of wood I mean these
things are fantastic so here what we're
gonna do with the help of our friends at
tilt comm we're gonna produce an
additional 500 wooden tilt comm /team
cocoa and like I said all proceeds all
proceeds go to the Children's Defense
Fund and in addition each wouldn't emoji
with this second edition will be carved
from 2-inch thick pine oh yeah but do
you think people are gonna be satisfied
with something that's only 2 inches
trust me Andy two inches can be very
satisfying
[Applause]
what if you buy one of the 500 emojis
you also get this official document
certifying that Andy Richter is against
us giving all the proceeds to charity I
wanted to use up to buy a boat oh yeah
and there's the boat right there that
Andy wanted to buy and he's not gonna
get I'm not gonna get my go to tilt calm
took on / team Coco and help a good
cause
[Applause]
you